breaking now an attempted bank robbery
holds traffic for hours near charleston
and las vegas boulevard police swarmed
the area trying to arrest that suspect
good afternoon thanks for joining us at
4 i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas let's get right out to victoria
saha live at the scene victoria good
afternoon
good afternoon to you guys this is a
very busy part of town police weren't
telling us which bank was the target but
this wells fargo is the only bank in the
area the area was blocked off for hours
the crime tape actually just recently
came down
details are very limited but police say
they received a call just after 12 this
afternoon about a robbery at a bank
police say there was no mention of a
weapon but without giving detailed
information police say the teller
assumed a robbery was unfolding based on
the suspect who walked in and police are
confirming it was a robbery as soon as
officers got on scene they say employees
and customers were leaving the building
but the suspect was still inside they
were able to set up around the building
and get information from those who were
still inside on what was happening swat
was called
upon their arrivals they took the
suspect into custody without incident
the area by charleston and las vegas
boulevard was closed down no one was
allowed near the area on foot or by car
i had bought a woman in a wheelchair the
wrong flavor of this and when i came
back to exchange it police across the
street told us to go back we weren't
allowed to be in this area he worried a
lot of people the police did a fabulous
job
police are still continuing their
investigation on this this wells fargo
will be closed for the rest of the day
for customers we did see quite a few
people walking up and then being turned
away reporting near charleston and las
vegas boulevard victoria saha live local
now